-Tonight was the second
Democratic debate,
or, as nine candidates
called it,
"Operation Destroy Joe Biden."
Everybody went after Biden,
but he said,
with 10 people onstage,
it was less of a debate
and more of like
a lightning round
Or, in Bernie Sanders' case,
a struck-by-lightning round.
Hey, you got to respect
a guy who combs his
hair with a balloon.
You know what I'm saying?
Then he floats away like
the old man from "Up."
It's amazing.
But it was a big night,
and, in the end, a lot of people
thought Kamala Harris
won the be debate.
She had what was probably --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. She had what was probably
the line of the night.
At one point, all the candidates
were talking over each other,
and that's when she stepped in
and dropped the hammer.
Watch this.
-Part of the issue of --
Hey, guys, you know what?
America does not want to
witness a food fight.
They want to
know how we're going to
put food on their table.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She was so good,
Trump endorsed Biden
so that he wouldn't
have to face her.
It's like, "Yeah, he's great."
Tonight, we got to see Bernie
and Biden onstage together.
Yeah, here they are right there.
Yeah.
It looks like they're debating
Viagra versus Cialis.
Look, I'm not saying those two
are old, but their podiums
were the only ones with tennis
balls the bottom.
But get this -- there was
a 40-year age difference
between tonight's candidates,
ranging from 37 to 77.
With Pete Buttigieg next to
Biden, it looked like
Take Your Kid to Work Day.
Speaking of Buttigieg,
he said Democrats need to
move the party forward
and claimed his opponents
want to return to the 1990s.
Hey, Pete, the top movies
right now are
"Toy Story," "Men in Black,"
and "Aladdin."
We're already back in the '90s.
Sorry to say.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, in addition to
the front-runners,
we also got to know
some of the underdogs,
and, early on, a lot of people
noticed that one of them,
Andrew Yang,
wasn't wearing a tie.
Take a look at this. Yeah.
When he realized you
can go casual,
Biden tried to take off
his pants,
and you go, "No, hey,
you can't do that."
Finally, you guys,
so much happened during
the two nights of the debate,
it's hard to cover it all.
so I was thinking we
could ask Tariq
for a debate rap recap.
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know the second debate just
ended 30 minutes ago,
but, Tariq,
what do you think, bud?
-I think we could pull that off.
-All right. Let's do this.
Roots, hit it.
♪♪
♪ They were, unh ♪
♪ They were short on time ♪
♪ 60 to respond
before they pass the baton ♪
♪ Before the record flies by
in a blink ♪
♪ But in Miami,
all the views were stunning ♪
♪ Everyone you know was there,
'cause everyone you know
was running ♪
♪ The first night, Liz Warren
came out feelin' big ♪
♪ Dunkin' on those candidates
like Zion in a wig ♪
♪ Cory Booker threw Shaft
side-eye ♪
♪ I thought she spoke faster ♪
♪ With people on the stage like
a Netflix password ♪
♪ Chuck Todd was focused ♪
♪ He avoided a snafu ♪
♪ Till it sounded like a
microphone
turned on in the bathroom ♪
♪ Tonight, the moderators
pretty much were irrelevant ♪
♪ 'Cause they were
getting trampled
like the Dems were elephants ♪
♪ Kamala spoke about Trump ♪
♪ She asked if he pays enough ♪
♪ And smoked him out like she
was in her blazer,
later blazin' up ♪
♪ Bernie Sanders said he's
pollin' better Donald is ♪
♪ Then he yelled about it as if
he was at the audiologist ♪
♪ Yang kept it cool ♪
♪ Mayor Pete kept it brainy ♪
♪ Joe's night was mainly rainy ♪
♪ Hey, what's up with
John Delaney? ♪
♪♪
♪ Elizabeth Warren
came ready for war ♪
♪ And the Beto O'Rourke camp is,
"Sí, señor" ♪
♪ And foreign policy was
on their minds ♪
♪ All the time ♪
♪ Are we in a case
of blind leading blind? ♪
♪ Who will keep the people tight
and safe at night? ♪
♪ Maybe Biden's teeth will be
the guiding light ♪
♪ Food fights, zinger ♪
♪ Rachel put 'em through
the ringer ♪
♪ Humdinger ♪
♪ Should they take another swing
or call it quits? ♪
♪ I can do this all day
and might slip ♪
♪ Might lose a grip ♪
♪ Might make
a blooper disappear quick
like I'm Hickenlooper with the
with the super-bang ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪